[Musica]
Buonasera a tutti e Innanzitutto grazie
mille essere qui sta sera e volevo farvi
una piccolissima confessione prima di
iniziare il mio discorso Questa sera Fon
x è da sempre da quando ero ragazzina su
la mia Bucket list che è la lista dei
sogni che uno vorrebbe avverare prima di
morire però vi dico anche un'altra cosa
io sono abbastanza abituata a parlare in
pubblico però mi faccio soli parlo nei
temi tecnici davanti a una platea di
esperti del settore Quindi per essere
qui stasera per dire di sì all'invito
degli organizzatori che ringrazio ho
dovuto veramente raccogliere tutto il
mio coraggio per scegliere di prendere
l'er e venire qui e quindi è proprio di
questo che voglio parlarvi Stas sera del
coraggio di scegliere condividendo con
voi alcune riflessioni sul tema che ho
murav nel corso della mia esperienza
allora perché parliamo del coraggio di
scegliere noi oggi viviamo in un mondo
che è sempre più imprevedibile in cui
l'unica vera costante è il continuo
cambiamento Chi di voi nel 2019 ha
poteva mai immaginare che nei tre AR a
seguire Avo avuto una pandemia una
guerra in Europa una crisi energetica
ora una crisi alimentare ambientale
domani vi cheni chi lo sa l'unica cosa
di cui siamo certi di cui possiamo
essere certi È che viviamo in uno
scenario che estremamente volatile e uno
scenario che lo sarà sempre di più e
quindi per sopravvivere per usare questa
vol agilità dobbiamo essere sempre più
flessibili e resilienti in tutti gli
aspetti della nostra vita ma soprattutto
nelle nostre scelte lavorative i nostri
genitori potevano pensare di iniziare un
percorso di carriera una scelta
lavorativa e seguire per quel percorso
quella traiettoria fino al pensionamento
oggi statisticamente i giovani che
iniziano a lavorare cambieranno in Medio
carriera sette volte nella loro vita
quindi scegliere diventa sempre più
difficile per per aiutare i giovani però
a superare questa sfida di scegliere in
un contesto che non possiamo prevedere
dobbiamo pensare a un nuovo patto
generazionale per costruire insieme il
futuro da un lato abbiamo i giovani i
giovani che sono chiamati a prere scelte
importanti ma trovano uno spazio molto
limitato per crescere e per sviluppare
il loro percorso e dall'altro abbiamo la
cl dirigente che stenta a portare avanti
il ricambio che è necessario ed èo
atteso abbiamo due giar a condotto che
devono saper entrambe scegliere con
coraggio Infatti i giovani devono
scegliere ora di ampliare i propri
orizzonti ti devono lasciare contaminare
da Mondi e da Ass stori che non
conoscono perché magari ancora non
esistono devono cogliere tutte le
opportunità che si presentano loro in
particolar modo Durante il loro periodo
di formazione devono Oh mio Dio e anche
per gestire problemi come questo devono
coltivare relazioni con chi è più inato
di loro e devono trovare de ventory e
Mod anche qu che mi aiutino a
riconoscere e
[Musica]
costruire un giovane tante nella vita
bello scelto essere qui stasera D invece
abbiamo la dirigente deve scegliere di
avere una visione la visione di
garantire accesso ai giovani al mondo
del lavoro la visione di coinvolgere i
giovani nei processi decisionali e nella
defizione di politiche che impatteranno
molto più il loro futuro che quello
delle persone che le stanno scegliendo
devono scegliere di avere la visione di
lasciare giovani ruoli di responsabilità
e lasciarli percorsi di carriera molto
più Rapid però dobbiamo anche renderci
conto che per fare questo vanno rivisti
i tempi della Formazione che in Italia
sono davvero lunghi e rallentano
l'insegnamento dei Giovani nel mondo del
lavoro e poi ne vanno riviste le
modalità perché oggi c'è un gravissimo
divario tra domanda delle aziende E le
competenze che sono offerte sul mercato
vi dico chiaramente che oggi c'è
qualcosa che non va nel nostro modello
formativo e trovo surreale la
intenditrice che cerca la gente da
assumere tutti i giorni che mentre le
aziende cercano disperatamente Talenti
ci sono tantissime persone a cap per
lavorare vi do due dati che trovo
veramente terribili uno che in Italia il
22,3 dei giovani non lavorano abbiamo
quasi un quarto della nostra popolazione
giovanile disoccupata è ancora più
devastante che i n che sono i giovani
che non studiano e non lavorano quindi
giovani che sono essenzialmente senza
futuro sono ben 3 milioni in Italia lo
trovo veramente terribile per il futuro
di questo paese e le aziende non hanno
persone da assumere quindi è evidente
che il nostro modello formativo ha
qualcosa che stamente non funziona e che
continua a non funzionare ed è anche
chiaro che oggi è urgentissimo
ripensarlo per renderlo stimolante da un
lato ma anche in grado di preparare i
giovani a un nuovo Mercato del Lavoro
con nuove competenze che cambieranno
sempre più rapidamente che domani non
saranno quelle di oggi e oggi non sono
quelle di ieri e quindi pensiamo un po'
a dei modelli virtuosi che possiamo
possiamo prendere ad esempio ad estero i
giovani vanno a lavorare poco più che
ventenni hanno subito ruoli di
responsabilità e vengono coinvolti in
processi decisionali da subito e vengono
messi in gioco l'ho visto io iniziando a
lavorare Io ho iniziato a lavorare a
Londra non avevo ancora 21 anni e nella
banca d' fare in cui lavoravo i giovani
ovviamente solo quelli bravi per carità
velocemente ricoprivano ruoli epicar ma
non solo io non ho mai visto lì a Londra
quando lavorava in in barca Sari una
donna dove mai Pore il problema di
scegliere tra figli e carriera perché
erano entrambe perfettamente
conciliabili invece in Italia succede
qualcosa che secondo me è
pericolosissimo moltissimi giovani si
laurano a 30 anni e il problema è molto
serio È molto serio perché il periodo
tra i 20 e i 30 anni di vita è il
periodo che è fatto per sperimentare per
rare e per sbagliare allungare di molti
anni il tempo della formazione di fatto
priva i giovani di quel danso di tempo
di quell guinetto che gli permette di
commettere errori di ricominciare da
Carlo e imparare quando sbagliano e
secondo me anche questo è un altro passo
molto importante che dobbiamo compiere
qui in Italia Dobbiamo cambiare il
nostro modo di pensare e promuovere una
cultura dell'accettazione dell'errore
che è quello che in inglese si dice
Start mindset
prodiag C ricominci da capo e non
succede niente perché va bene così
dobbiamo innovare il modello formativo
italiano ma dobbiamo anche abbattere
Laura che condanna Senza Misura l'errore
Perché noi dobbiamo massimizzare il
potenziale dei giovani e anche il loro
inserimento produttivo nella nostra
società che ne ha molto bisogno e poi ve
lo devo dire c'è un altro ostacolo che
ver fin ora non ha reso possibile il
cambiamento ed è un fatore puntuale
molto molto molto italiano legato alla
scarta considerazione verso i giovani
per motivi puramente anagrafici e questo
è un'altra cosa che io ho sperimentato
su me stessa quando sono tornata a
vivere in Italia qualche anno fa da
Londra e ho visto quanto diversamente mi
trattavano qui per le mentare in
confronto a come aveva trata lì qualche
mese prima e quindi vi dico che
purtroppo qui in Italia l'autorevolezza
percepita di una persona è direttamente
cerata Cor relata alla sua età
anagrafica e questo non va
bene bisognerà rimettere Secondo me alle
persone il ruolo che si Mericano in base
loro capacità e non in base alla loro
età o al loro genere e dobbiamo
lasciarci ispirare da un principio di
inclusione che è inteso con un'e equità
intergenerazionale e di genere che sono
due elementi A mio avviso fondamentali
per scrivere la storia Futura che
vogliamo per questo paese il futuro va
costruito insieme ai giovani che sono
sempre troppo tagliati fuori e troppo
penalizzati dal mancato ricambio
generazionale e con le donne che
tutt'ora anche adesso nel 2023 si
trovano sempre ai margini del mondo
lavorativo dobbiamo arrenderci a un
cambiamento che di fatto è già in atto e
Ricordiamoci una cosa è molto importante
Oggi l'Italia continua a crescere ci
vantiamo di questo Boom italiano ma non
è garantito e se noi non non Cambiamo il
modo in cui in cui pensiamo in cui
lavoriamo in cui viviamo se non
innoviamo il nostro modello è molto più
probabile che torneremo alla stagnazione
che ci ha caratterizzati per decenni
prima di adesso lo sviluppo del nostro
paese Dipenderà dalla nostra capacità di
saper coinvolgere tutte le risorse a
disposizione e n saper valorizzare il
capitale umane che il capitale umano
Scusate che oggi abbiamo e per questo
dobbiamo puntare anche su un'altra cosa
che è un sistema di welfare strumento
chiave per superare disparità di genere
e di vario generazionale che sono due
fenomeni che riguardano Come dicevamo
donne e giovani D due categorie più
fragili purtroppo è così perché i due
più grandi ostacoli allo sviluppo di
questo paese sono da un lato la mancanza
partecipazione delle donne al mondo nel
lavoro perché diversamente da quello che
ho visto io in Inghilterra qui le donne
troppo spesso l'abbiamo visto durante il
covid sono costrette a scegliere
famiglia e carriera gli uomini no e
dall'altro dobbiamo pensare molto
attentamente al divario generazionale
che vi vi definisco perché vi leggo la
definizione che la difficoltà che un
giovane deve affrontare per raggiungere
le principali tappe di una vita autonoma
e di realizzazione personale e
professionale e i giovani in questo
momento ancora sentono de avere speranze
ma il wif può veramente an un antio alla
degenerazione di un sistema in Italia
che è segnato da una forte Den natalità
e che sta diventando veramente
insostenibile a livello sia sociale che
politico se continuiamo con i Trend
attuali noi nel 2050 che è tra meno di
20 anni non è non è un anuro molto
lontano avremo 12 milioni di persone
over 75 con effetti veramente devastanti
sulla tenuta sociale ed economica di
questo paese e quindi cosa possiamo fare
beh potremmo trarre spunto da altri
altri paesi in Europa o nel mondo che
hanno avuto problemi simili e li hanno
affrontati vi faccio l'esempio della
Francia la Francia oggi è Unity che
spende di più in Fam in westf familiare
e ne stare vendo i crussi perché ad oggi
è il paese col più alto tasso di nascite
in Europa 20 anni fa non era così È
chiaro che non ci sono ricette sicure
per cambiare il futuro ma quello che può
veramente a mio avviso fare la
differenza per tutti noi è il coraggio
di compiere delle scelte ispirate da un
patto generazionale che deve guidare il
cambiamento in questo scenario che vi
sto delineando i leader di oggi devono
spianare la strada ai leader di domani
costruendo insieme con loro il furo
abbracciando la prospettiva dei giovani
e la prospettiva delle donne e de loro
valori perché questi devono diventare
attori chiave nel processo decisionale
per costruire il mondo che vogliamo oggi
in Italia si parla sempre di pnrr quindi
non potevano impare un passaggio su
questo perché con i fondi del pnrr
Abbiamo veramente la possibilità di
immaginare soluzione in grado di
generare un impatto duraturo per tutte
le generazioni per tutte le categorie e
per un futuro sostenibile
come tutte le grandi occasioni anche
questa deriva da un momento di crisi che
ha toccato in maniera più dannosa le
categorie più fragili quindi giovani e
donne quindi non è a caso che uno dei
dei dei temi trasversali del tnr è
appunto sia l'inclusione di genere e
l'inclusione
generazionale Vorrei chiudere il mio
intervento di oggi dicendovi che in
questo momento abbiamo veramente una
grandissima opportunità per costruire
politiche nuove a prova di futuro Ma che
futuro va costruito insieme e quindi vi
voglio lasciare con Un antico proverbio
africano che recita se vuoi andare
veloce vai da solo ma se vuoi andare
lontano Vai insiene Grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]
tante